[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con hoy
hablaremos sobre el reciente informe
publicado por amnistía internacional en
el que se indican las medidas esenciales
que deben adoptarse para orientar la
vacunación en américa latina contra el
coi 19 y también en el caribe desde
nueva york que nos acompaña a mailín
kidman investigadora regional para las
américas de amnistía internacional y
autora de este informe gracias por
acompañarnos señor a permanecer aquí con
nosotros en francia en ticul estás
gracias buenos días buenos y haciendo
américa latina y el caribe la región más
desigual del mundo es suficiente en
términos generales lo que están haciendo
los gobiernos para garantizar la
vacunación de todos llevamos un año de
pandemia y las tasas de contagios siguen
al alza realmente los gobiernos de la
región tienen que hacer más porque este
es un momento y una oportunidad para un
esfuerzo colaborativo donde las voces de
todas las personas estén escuchadas
entonces hasta ahora de los 17 países
que estudiamos de américa latina y el
caribe para este informe sólo 13 han
publicado sus planes de vacunación
entonces son varios
ni siquiera han dado una hoja de ruta
clara a sus poblaciones en cuanto a qué
van a hacer esos son los que faltan son
venezuela ecuador cuba y nicaragua y
estamos también esperando que uruguay
sea un poco más claro y transparente con
sus planes de los tres países que se han
publicado sus planes hay también fallas
pero están haciendo también los
gobiernos obviamente un esfuerzo
titánico en este momento esto se tiene
que reconocer de esta fórmula de su
funcionalmente no no obstante los
pueblos indígenas las personas
afrodescendientes siguen siendo hasta
cierto punto excluidas y las personas
migrantes es muy preocupante que varios
países no estén tomando en cuenta que
las personas refugiadas inmigrantes
deben ser prioritarias porque no debe
existir un documento ni nada parecer
vacunadores virus no tiene fronteras y
en
un continente con muchísima movilidad
humana es importante ese punto ahora
madeleine hablemos de la corrupción en
el sector sanitario y su vínculo con la
capacidad limitada de los estados para
afrontar esta pandemia cómo podría ir
esto en detrimento del acceso a todas
las vacunas de hecho ya lo estamos
viendo en algunos países bueno de hecho
américa latina y el caribe
desafortunadamente sale bastante mal en
los índices globales de corrupción y el
sector salud es un sector
más notorio de hecho de la región por
la corrupción entonces tomando eso en
cuenta lo que los estados de la región
tiene que hacer es fortalecer sus
órganos de transparencia poder hacer a
sus fiscales de anticorrupción y
realmente hacer que
cualquier compra que se haga de la
vacuna sea una compra transparente
es parte de un plan nacional de
vacunación y que realmente cualquier
compra regular o cualquier
se dan tiene que ser seleccionado y
fiscalizado en el momento entonces eso
es muy importante tampoco se puede
abusar del poder para acceder a la
vacuna obviamente tenemos muchos
ejemplos de eso así smile en todo lo que
usted ha dicho pues ha sido muy
importante le pregunto qué situación
encontraron ustedes en el desarrollo de
este informe frente a los derechos
laborales de los profesionales de la
salud y los funcionarios estatales que
deben gestionar también la pandemia en
sus países si como decía hay que
reconocer que llevamos un año de
servidores públicos y también de
personal sanitario realmente cansándose
a lo máximo a demasiado ya estamos
hablando de una crisis de salud mental
de personal sanitaria en toda la región
estamos hablando de una crisis de
derechos laborales tomemos el ejemplo de
venezuela donde una enfermera en
venezuela gana cuatro dólares al mes
de hecho menos ahora porque esos fueron
votantes de octubre tomemos el ejemplo
del señor jorgito sobre el cual tenemos
una campaña global con jito fue un señor
limpiador de hospital público de mexico
que levantó su voz cuando levantó su voz
por las pésimas condiciones laborales
que tenían y le despidieron y ahora
tenemos una campaña sobre el entonces
realmente no debe ser ninguna causa de
represar le a levantar la voz por las
malas condiciones que tienen las
personas sanitarias entonces todo a
personas trabajadoras sanitarias deben
ser vacunadas sea persona que limpia
hospital sea enfermera sea médico
etcétera
mailen gracias por estar aquí con
nosotros en france 24 que tenga usted un
feliz resto de ustedes también gracias
por acompañarnos
[Música]